[Music]
top gun Maverick is a movie where a big
movie star plays a man who rides a
motorcycle
poses behind American flags says things
like Show Me What You're Made Of and
uses the power of grit determination
will a little teamwork to overcome any
challenge he's faced with
[Music]
despite its massive success it's also a
movie that feels wildly out of place in
2022 it's a little-known law of the
universe that anywhere there's a
discussion being had about top gun
Maverick you can find the phrase they
don't make them like that anymore laying
around close by but when people say that
what exactly do they mean people aren't
referring to the fact that Tom Cruise
and the rest of the cast flew their own
aircraft this honestly has never been
how they were made they didn't even do
this for the original Top Gun and Tom
Cruise himself has been doing plenty of
this crazy do your own stunts kind of
stuff in very recent years so if we want
to figure out what Maverick has that
they don't make anymore we first have to
ask ourselves what do they make them
like now this video is sponsored by mubi
go to movie.com thomasflight for your
extended 30-day free trial
scene 17 take one Mark gonna be a
hundred more Jack Conrad
100 more means 100 more conversations
just like this one over and over again
until God knows when
we're doing is important right
what we document so
it's gonna do some good
huh
at a time when cultural anxiety about
the state of the world is escalating on
many fronts many artists seem to be
turning their attention inward to
examine the validity of the art they
love and the mediums they work within
don't worry sometimes just entertain
myself
might I Stave off the inevitable movies
have gained an increasingly
self-referential bent the value of the
art of movies and the institutions that
are required to make them are being
questioned by those who love it most
dearly
mirror chasing
the one where you end up at the top of
the mountain
all eyes on you
Supreme and never wake up from
here I come oh here I come oh
but in the midst of this self-reflection
the movies still want to be movies okay
it's off
I can see a red light they aren't just
deconstructing the value of art or film
but are caught in conflict with
themselves containing deconstructive
self-criticism and sentimental sincerity
together an earthquake could wipe this
town off the map and it wouldn't make a
difference
it's the idea that sticks
just in the year 2022 we saw nope which
criticizes spectacle even as it tries to
be one the Banshees of inner Sharon
which is in dialogue with itself about
the value of art we saw Steven Spielberg
looking back at his own life in the
fablemans and examining the Royal Cinema
has played in it for both good and bad
through Cinema the menu critiques not
just the artist but our Collective
response to artists after sun framed its
story within the context of memories
being recorded by its characters which
reflected its reality as an
autobiographical film and Damien
chazelle's Babylon examined the excesses
of the film industry and the way it's
alienated people while celebrating why
Cinema can be so exciting using Cinema
and then we saw everything everywhere
all at once which feels like the
culmination of something new it explodes
into a chaotic Whirlwind of film Styles
and references declaring everything
meaningless in the midst of this chaos
and then somehow still finding meaning
there but I don't think it it's just
these self-aware a24 dramas or movies
about filmmaking I felt a shift in the
way movies feel across the board it
seems like there's very little
straightforward storytelling in film
anymore movies are either part of a
multi-dimensional franchise or are
satirical surreal or absurd they might
contain a Multiverse or twists on a
classic Trope break storytelling
convention or some combination of all
those things and some of these elements
have been around in the movies for a
long time there have always been movies
about making movies or art but I think
more recently these things have gone
from the occasional novelty to the norm
and with that there's a distinct shift
in tone that we can identify and
describe one that is part of a broader
cultural shift
this is the meta modern
film
you got this
what really makes Top Gun feel like a
throwback is its complete lack of irony
self-consciousness or self-doubt there's
no subversion of well-established tropes
there's not a big twist where we find
out Maverick is actually the bad guy
it's not an anti-hero story it's a
sequel to another well-known film but
it's a sequel of pretty much the most
straightforward kind imaginable there's
no spin-off or Multiverse here top gun
Maverick is a rare thing these days I
think it's what we could call a
modernist movie and modernism is the
thing they don't make them like anymore
in this video I'm going to argue that
the shift in how movies feel can be
described as a shift first from
modernism to post-modernism and then
from post-modernism into the meta
modernism we see now to really
understand that shift and what
meta-modernism looks like in film we
first need to broadly understand both
modernism and post-modernism in film
because meta-modernism is reacting to
both of them and incorporating both of
them into itself
thank you
all three of the big isms we're talking
about here are kind of hard to pin down
philosophers are critics and media
critics all disagree on what exactly
they are and how to best describe them
some people refer to modernism
post-modernism and metamodernism as eras
of thought philosophy or even art
movements some academics refer to these
three as structures of feeling and
that's the sense in which I'm going to
be using them in this video a structure
of feeling is essentially A culture-wide
vibe that encompasses philosophy
politics design and most importantly for
this video art so in the case of
modernism we're giving a name to a
specific culture-wide vibe that starts
to show up in philosophy with Descartes
as early as the 1600s and then continues
through to Nietzsche but which really
shows up in culture and art from the
1900s to the 1940s film itself is a
modernist medium the technology started
to emerge right as modernism was hitting
the culture in the same way science and
reason seemed to provide a more
objective view of reality than tradition
did photography seems to provide a more
objective image of the world than
paintings did and in a sense filming 24
photos a second presented the most
startlingly real and immersive images
art had ever been able to create I think
in this way the form of film kind of
ideologically aligned with modernist
philosophies that promoted this idea of
an objective view of reality so in a lot
of ways I think modernism is kind of the
default state of Cinema but we can get a
little more specific than that there are
movies that feel modernist not just
because of their traditional
storytelling structure or filmmaking but
because they specifically promote
modernist philosophies or values
[Music]
returning to top gun Maverick is going
to help us understand modernism here the
movie's sincerity and traditional story
structure are a big part of what makes
it feel modernist to me but I think
another big element of its modernism is
the way it displays specific values and
then unapologetically seems to argue for
those values as good and beneficial
success
now more than ever comes down to the man
or woman in the Box Maverick is
embodying the American values of
individualism freedom and determination
to do what nobody else is willing to do
and by embodying these values along with
his Superior jet flying skills Maverick
is able to accomplish his goals and
defeat the bad guys but not before
learning a lesson that other people can
help out sometimes too
Marshall turn in your badge
I tell you the truth I kind of hate to
do this without your new Marshall being
here in the 1952 film High Noon U.S
Marshal will Kane just got married and
is about to give up his badge and leave
town when he receives word that an
outlaw he once locked up Frank Miller
has been released and is going to arrive
on the train at noon to take his Revenge
by killing Kane for his new wife who is
a Quaker pacifist the solution is simple
just leave town but Kane has a sense of
responsibility and duty to his station
since there's no new Marshall to replace
him yet and he believes staying is the
smartest decision for him to make
they're making me run I've never run
from anybody before the film is well
staged and shot it's pretty tense
there's a decent amount of nuance here
it's a classic Western but in the broad
Strokes through the power of His
determination to take a stand that
nobody else will there's that American
individualism again and his dedication
to honor along with his Superior
gunslinging skills Kane is able to
defeat the bad guy but not before he
learns the lesson that other people can
help out too sometimes
this is a great example I think because
it shows how modernism is itself
responding to Traditional Values I know
it's against your religion though Amy
ultimately rejects her Quaker beliefs
and pacifism in order to side with
Kane's modernist values which are
grounded in his sense of civic duty to
the democratic government the movie
strongly puts forward that Cain being a
good martial has clearly made the town a
better place clean this town up you made
it fit for women and kids to live in
modernism is looking at traditional
governments art and religion and saying
a lot of the seems kind of flawed why
aren't you in church why aren't you and
if we apply the tools of science reason
and rationalism we can become more
enlightened beings that have a more
objective understanding of the truth and
are therefore better and make the world
a better place because of it person
you got anything to say I don't know
your traditional religion is depicted as
not really having answers for the moral
dilemma that Cain is facing the right
and the wrong seem pretty clear here
but if you're asking me to tell my
people to go out and kill and maybe get
themselves killed
I'm sorry I don't know what to say
instead the film sense that Kane is
making the right decision is grounded in
a kind of democratic weighing of
different views there's a difference of
opinion let everybody ever say but let's
do it like grown-up people and
ultimately Kane's own reasoning but the
movie isn't just modernist in its values
it's also modernist in another way it's
storytelling structure what's really
surprising about watching a film like
this now seven years later is not just
its unabashedly sincere advocation for
Honor Duty and being able to shoot
really good it's that there are pretty
much no twists it just sets up its story
and then
good guy wins bad guy loses
[Music]
for audiences who have grown up on
postmodern and meta-modern media this is
going to feel uncannily straightforward
I want to be clear about two things
first I don't think every movie during
the early period of film is a modernist
one I think there were even some
post-modern films during this time
although the language to describe them
as that didn't exist yet and second I
don't think these filmmakers were
intentionally engaging with modernism or
trying to make modernist stories they
just existed in a largely modernist
culture and so those modernist values
and ideas came through in the kinds of
stories they told the important takeaway
here is that this General traditional
story structure advocacy of specific
values and generally optimistic feeling
was the dominant one in film for a while
and this is largely the modernism that
post-modernism in film is responding to
[Music]
handle on what post-modernism in film
looks like let's look at No Country for
Old Men one of my favorite
post-modernist movies which deconstructs
the Western and is a great comparison to
High Noon
call it in this neo-western gone is the
villain with the straightforward motive
of a grudge and his place is an aimless
imposing figure who seems to have no
morality beyond the arbitrary whims of
fate
in High Noon there's this character the
older previous martial before Cain if
you're honest you're poor your whole
life and in the end you wind up dying
all alone on some dirty Street you can
almost hear him giving voice to the
postmodernist anxiety that would have
been starting to arise in the 50s but
while high noon brushes this character
aside in favor of Kane's modernist sense
of Morality In No Country for Old Men
it's this world weary perspective that
takes center stage in the form of the
sheriff oh that's all right I laughed
myself sometimes
laughs and a whole lot else you can do
Kane's confidence self-assurance and
unwavering conviction about right and
wrong is replaced by a sheriff who does
his job but laments the state of things
wondering if he even wants to be a part
of the world he sees around him
Llewellyn the other key protagonist
meanwhile isn't a hero he's not
motivated by Honor or Duty he's just
trying to get away with a bag of money
that he accidentally found this isn't a
gunslinger but a gunslinger
deconstructed I'm not going to spoil the
movie but let's just say it doesn't
unfold with the kind of Hollywood ending
we get in high noon instead things just
unspool as if the outcome of the plot
was decided by the flip of a coin if
High Noon is saying the good guys will
win because they have honor Duty and
determination No Country for Old Men is
a tad more nihilistic
post-modernism in film arose as
questioning modernist values became more
than Norm in the broader culture as the
20th century wore on and the world wars
gave way to the possibility of nuclear
annihilation in the war in Vietnam and
as decolonization and civil rights gave
way for previously disempowered voices
to speak up about how they'd been harmed
a whole way of life a whole system of
thought
which has kept me in prison until this
hour many people began to question
whether or not modernist values were
actually objectively good and really
making things better for everybody so
here post-modernism steps in and
importantly instead of returning to
traditional narratives starts to
question the value of narrative itself
postmodernism is kind of saying maybe
this idea that we can come to an
understanding of the objective truth
using science and reason is itself a
narrative like the narratives of old in
Tradition that modernism rejected
post-modernism is also looking at things
like the rise of fascism in the 20th
century and understanding how the
narrative surrounding that are part of
what made it a powerful force for evil
in the 20th century postmodernism and
Broad Strokes is really critiquing
modernism by critiquing narrative itself
saying maybe we should be skeptical of
any broad overarching narrative that
thinks it can explain the world and when
you start to question the value of
narrative itself in what is essentially
a narrative form things understandably
start to get a little weird as we move
towards the end of the 20th century in
film history we start to see more and
more movies that don't just question and
deconstruct modernist values but which
also start to deconstruct the way
stories are told in film
I thought you said you were a writer
this post-modern skepticism of narrative
starts to show up in deconstructions of
modernist filmmaking many of which draw
attention to the act of Storytelling
time becomes fragmented in movies like
Pulp Fiction fourth walls are broken
stories become more self-aware sincere
storytelling gives way to irony Pastiche
surrealism and self-reflexivity genre
conventions are deconstructed
if modernist films were trying to create
an illusion of reality so that you the
viewer could suspend your disbelief and
become fully engrossed in the film some
postmodernist films were trying to
remind the viewer that they were a
viewer and that everything they were
seeing was a story and that stories are
constructed and that the director and
actors are the ones controlling the
narrative
I think another great example of a
post-modernist film is Monty Python's
quest for the Holy Grail where
everything is just kind of one big joke
[Music]
by the end even the film itself is
treated as a big joke
the story never gets resolved because
why take it seriously why take anything
seriously the characters aren't real the
place isn't real this isn't even real
but I think post-modernism especially in
narrative forms eventually runs its
course you can only deconstruct things
for so long before everything kind of
turns into chaos you can only subvert
expectations so many times before the
new expectation becomes that
expectations will be subverted and it
all kind of starts to get a little bit
old irony and cynicism are hard to
sustain they eventually get tiring while
post-modernism might have some very
valid critiques to level against
modernism showing how it created a bunch
of problems in the 20th century
post-modernism itself didn't do anything
to really solve those problems nor has
it prevented or solved all the new
problems we have in the 21st century so
as our fears of increased polarization
late stage capitalism and climate change
are added on top of pre-existing fears
from the 20th century like nuclear
Annihilation that never really went away
I think people start to kind of long for
a sort of modernist optimism again that
maybe we can actually figure out a way
to solve some of these problems and make
things better post-modern deconstruction
can be helpful for a while but it can
also give you a kind of cynicism that
tears everything down and leaves you
unable to sincerely engage with anything
and people want meaning deconstructing
all the ways we find narrative
meaningful doesn't suddenly remove our
desire for it or make the Comfort it
provides disappear people still want to
go see a movie people still want to tell
stories and listen to stories
so what comes after post
[Music]
and now it's time for what I know you've
all been waiting for by the time we get
to 2022 with a movie like everything
everywhere all at once many of the
elements of post-modernism still remain
the movie is a never-ending Pastiche of
pop culture and film references much in
the same way the postmodern Pulp Fiction
was everything everywhere constantly
plays on genre tropes and has a
silliness that Rivals a film like Monty
Python and the Holy Grail all while
leaning heavily into a nihilist
postmodern deconstruction of modernist
philosophy like we see in something like
No Country for Old Men Wright is a tiny
box invented by people who are afraid
but unlike the postmodern films
everything everywhere all at once also
contains a sincere depiction of
sentiment that most post-modern movies
never have it also harnesses a sort of
optimism and emotional sincerity that
Rivals that of modernist films like high
noon or top gun Maverick meta modernism
in general can be thought of as a
response to post-modernism
I'm something and it builds on
post-modernism right it's not just an
opposition to post-modernism I mean
everything everywhere all at once
nihilism is a big theme but if it were
merely a post-modern film it would stop
there but instead in one of the
culminating scenes Evelyn the mother she
and her daughter reconcile by accepting
the nihilism that I will cherish
these few specks of time
life means nothing and therefore it
means everything instead of just life
means nothing so it's like a meta-modern
update
of a post-modern Insight one of the ways
metamodern media responds to
post-modernism and modernism is by
swinging wildly back and forth between
modernist sincerity and post-modern
deconstruction this is what a lot of
meta-modern commentators call
oscillation there's more to
metamodernism than this but this is one
of the easy ways to identify it what
this means practically is that a lot of
metamodern films still use or contain
the techniques of post-modernist film an
example of this is the self-aware meta
elements in the movies that I
highlighted at the beginning of this
video this meta self-awareness is what
academics and media critics often call
self-reflexivity this self-reflexivity
was originally used by a lot of
post-modern films but it's still used by
meta-modern films so how do we tell the
difference between post-modern and
meta-modern metanus in post-modernism
this meta self-awareness is usually used
to draw attention to the limitation
structure boundaries or subjectivity of
the work itself for example what are you
doing oh I'm making that video about
metamodernism I'm right in the middle of
explaining how self-reflexivity is used
to call attention to the context of a
work yeah but why isn't this just a
bunch of academic over assessment of
artists self-obsessing about their own
work don't people just want to enjoy
their entertainment and peace that's a
good question I think a big part of why
we see this kind of self-reflexivity is
that viewers and artists feel sort of
self-conscious about art that is just
passive entertainment there's a lot of
concern about things that are happening
in the world things we see in the news
every day and there might be a feeling
that maybe we should do something about
that and if you are involved in creating
a multi-million dollar art project for
entertainment you might be asking
yourself you know should I be doing
something better with my time exactly
self-obsession well I think that
self-consciousness also extends to the
viewer post-modern self-reflexivity is
drawing the viewer's attention to the
fact that what you're seeing might feel
really compelling But ultimately it's
flawed and subjective like me breaking
the fourth wall to inject a counter
argument sure one interpretation of this
moment could be that it's deconstructing
the video essay format by reminding the
viewer that I'm just a guy who's reading
what I've written in a script and I have
my doubts about what I'm saying which
I'm representing in you as my double
okay then what's the difference between
postmodern and meta-modern
self-reflexivity so we've already
mentioned how a sketch like this is a
great example of post-modern
self-reflexivity by deconstructing the
video essay yeah but you're not using
this meta layer just to deconstruct the
video essay or yourself you're actually
using it to construct a more effective
argument for what you're trying to say
right I'm affirming what I'm doing is
worthwhile if nothing else for me
because I like this kind of
deconstruction and examination of art
okay I think I get it So Meta modernism
is just post-modernism but more
optimistic and less cynical that would
be probably a bit of an
oversimplification but you're definitely
on the right track so what we just did
was we went from the video essay format
to this which is a postmodern
deconstructive self-reflexive meta
sketch and then we oscillated back into
a more modernist optimism that tries to
find Value in this video by grounding
that value in my own personal experience
while not ignoring the flaws and
critiques that you've acknowledged while
still holding on to an awareness of the
limitations I think it's true that a lot
of the tropes or aesthetic methods that
meta modernism employs have the exact
equivalent in post-modernism and the
differences in what they're saying with
it
the 1996 Coen Brothers movie Fargo opens
with this text this is a true story the
events depicted in this film took place
in Minnesota in 1987. at the request of
the survivors the names have been
changed out of respect for the dead the
rest has been told exactly as it occurs
except the Coen Brothers eventually
admitted that nothing about the story
was true Joel Cohen saying in an
interview the only thing true about it
is that it's a story to me this is a
post-modern framing device one that is
deconstructing the way that narrative
films claim to be based on true stories
it's playing on that Trope in some sense
to provoke us into considering the fact
that even movies that claim to be based
on true stories are often largely a
fabrication now compare this to the
opening statement for Donald Glover's
recent show swarm any similarity to
actual persons living or dead or actual
events is intentional to me this is a
meta modern Twist on the same framing
device it's saying sure this is
fictional but within in that fiction
there's truth metamodernism begin to
emerge in the 90s and in film began to
really take form throughout the 2000s
one of the key early figures in movies
is Wes Anderson who really showcases how
Pastiche reference and metanarrative
framing devices can be used in a
meta-modernist way Wes is using all of
these things to call attention to the
act of Storytelling but not to
deconstruct story instead he uses it to
Revel in the value of stories themselves
using those stories as an Avenue to
communicate heartfelt emotions and I
think we can see how some directors who
started out doing very post-modernist
work like Tarantino have become more
meta modern if Pulp Fiction subverted
audience Expectations by deconstructing
the Hollywood ending Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I think one of the best
examples of metamodernism in film
recently subverts Expectations by
deconstructing a true story to give us a
Hollywood ending I think we're starting
to see metamodernism all over film and
TV now not just in media that is
explicitly self-aware or
self-referential but also in genre
deconstructing shows like succession
Atlanta Barry more recently beef and
even in reality TV shows like jury duty
all of which keenly balance both comedy
and a kind of ironic Detachment with
truly sincere heartfelt dramatic
sentiment you might wonder why culture
and art have moved into metamodernism as
a reaction to post-modernism instead of
just returning to modernism or tradition
and there are some attempts to just
return to those as with top gun Maverick
but I think those are the exceptions
rather than the norm from an artistic
filmmaking perspective we can't so
easily undo post-modernism's impact on
what is considered to be a normal
entertaining way to tell a story now
Greg pointed out how many of the
postmodern elements of Storytelling are
in and of themselves pretty fun but at
this postmodern art often just didn't
leave very much room for personal
meaning in the midst of that when you
get into meta-modern forums including
film you can't just go backwards and and
forget about all that stuff or or
viewers will think you're you don't get
it viewers will think you're cheesy or
corny
So Meta modern stuff has a way of
working all of the fun post-modern games
in but doing it in such a way that it
preserves a sense of interiority of
personal interiority or or what I often
call felt experience
but another reason that Greg proposed
for why metamodernism is developing that
I agree with is that it isn't just a
response to post-modernism it's also
simultaneously a response to something
we could call hyper modernism you have
modernity then post-modernism kind of
comes along but it's modernity doesn't
just stop existing then I mean it's it
kind of continues as a thread that now
is still this thing that we would
describe as hyper modernity yeah
everything everywhere all at once it's
whole you know metaphor of the um
multiple realities
I think is a metaphor for the way life
in the real world often feels like we're
in multiple realities and so so the
insane pace of change and of um
narrative switching and flipping and
points of view and to be able to be
aware of the points of view of people
from all over the world and people who
have diametrically opposed political
views to you all coming at you is
something that we have to deal with very
much now and it threatens to
pull apart your sense of self now we
make art that's not just protecting the
self from other art that was undermining
myself but we make art that protects the
sense of self from the world that we
live in moment to moment as we just go
about our lives whatever modernity was
has continued in in some senses
intensified you have people who are
trying to deconstruct those things they
continue yeah kind of in this other
trajectory but they don't necessarily
negate right each other one doesn't get
to win culturally right and all of the
traditional stuff is still right there
right it's still right there as well the
traditional stuff we would we would die
like we like right I mean that's just
the basic fabric that's writing
everything together the hyper modern
world is one where because of the
internet and social media we're
constantly inundated with traditional
modernist and post-modernist narratives
all at once the digital citizen has a
perspective of the world that was never
before possible this is something I talk
about in the video I made about hyper
modernism and everything everywhere all
at once last year metamodernism I think
is an attempt to make sense of this New
Perspective to pick and choose positive
elements from each of these old
philosophies and to recognize the
Multiverse that exists around us while
still trying to stay grounded in the
reality of what is truly meaningful in
front of you unlike No Country for Old
Men which deconstructs the Western genre
everything everywhere all at once
doesn't deconstruct a genre it
transcends genre it understands that in
the hyper modern world genre isn't a box
that you either have to fit into or
deconstruct now it is just another tool
in the storyteller's toolbox
[Music]
be right out we can really see how this
plays out in the western sequences from
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood where
Tarantino presents the act of filming a
Western in the style of a western if No
Country for Old Men is deconstructing
the Western genre conventions that we
find in high noon then once upon a time
in Hollywood is simultaneously
deconstructing and drawing our attention
to those conventions while reinforcing
their sort of inherent value and using
them to entertain the viewer whatever
meta modernism is we're still in the
midst of it it's still emerging and
being defined there's at least one
interview of Daniel Quan one of the two
Daniels who created everything
everywhere all at once where the writer
who's interviewing him tries to describe
it as post-modern and they're talking
about the way it references you know a
bunch of other films and Daniel Quan
kind of gently corrects her and says
well it's not so much much postmodern
it's it's I would say meta modern and he
explains what he means by that he says
something along the lines of that their
references are in their
to kind of say this is actually the
world that we all live in like we in our
lives we now live in a world where we're
inundated
with narratives coming from all over the
place and we feel through those
narratives and so everything everywhere
all at once if you catch a reference to
something like rat tattooey or whatever
you don't just stop at the chuckle in
the wink and the nod it
it brings in a I don't know how to
really describe it but um it brings in a
feeling of like connection
metamodernism itself isn't good or bad
it's not a style or a technique or even
something I necessarily think artists
should consciously try to apply to their
work it's just a reflection of changes
in cultural attitude feeling and
philosophy that I think naturally start
to appear in our storytelling some meta
modernist stuff to me feels like it's
overly concerned with its own self-doubt
sometimes I think storytellers should
just get on with it tell the story and
stop worrying about whether storytelling
is Meaningful in some kind of ultimate
sense it's not absolutely not necessary
for somebody to be aware of meta
modernism as a trend they can enjoy and
appreciate
everything just on its own terms and you
know they should that's mainly what they
what I hope people would be doing but
for the kind of people who think in this
way I feel like it creates
it creates a story about the stories you
then can appreciate any particular
individual artwork as its own thing but
you can then also appreciate it as kind
of fitting into this larger quilt sort
of that's
going on there is a thing there I don't
think like we're just making it up right
and so then being able to tune into that
and tap into that I think just adds
another layer of richness to our
experience metamodernism I think brings
back an appreciation for storytelling
for just its own sake because it's
something we enjoy if post-modernism
breaks the fourth wall in order to take
you out of the story then meta-modernism
breaks the fourth wall to open the story
up and invite you in because we love a
good story
so while I've been working on this video
I've also been in the process of moving
into a new office sorry about the mess
and while I was doing that I wanted to
show you
this these are the storyboards for the
new park Chan Luke film decision to
leave that I got to see last year at can
which is out now exclusively on mubi my
sponsor for this video movie was kind
enough to send me these storyboards and
just flipping through them really gives
you a sense of the detail and precision
that went into every second of decision
to leave if you've seen the movie you
know that there's so many crazy
transitions editing choices
cinematography choices and these
storyboards really show how all of that
was intricately planned ahead of time
movie's been the longest running sponsor
of my channel and I love their platform
a lot it's not just a place where you
can go to watch hand curated exceptional
films from all around the world it's
also just an amazing resource in terms
of curating International Indie Art
House Classic Cinema that you wouldn't
have access to anywhere else I'm
constantly going on mubi and discovering
something that I didn't know about
before but that quickly becomes a new
favorite of mine when you sign up at
movie.com
thomasflight you'll get an extended
30-day free trial so you can give it a
shot check out their library and watch
decision to leave for free on me with
that extended free trial go sign up at
movie.com thomasflight that's mubi.com
thomasflight thanks again to movie for
the cool gift and for making videos like
this possible
thank you